you also mentioned Indiana Jones that's
a weird that's a different one how do
you work with a like a with a famous
protagonist like uh when the character
is known
how do you work with that
well
it's different it's different like
Indiana Jones is different where like
the name he it is the like it's Indiana
Jones not a world it's him right you can
talk about the world Vineyard Jones but
at the end of the day it's about this
character
um and Raiders still my favorite movie
of all time no debate it's the best
movie ever
um best movie ever ever
on a tangent what do you love about it
uh well you know I saw it obviously when
I was younger and I believed it I
believe this happened and when they
found the ark I literally I I could not
believe that they found it so
and I have found over my life
it's still really watchable every time I
enjoy it every single time
um love the character love the story
um the opening is the greatest movie
opening ever and
I just love everything I love everything
about it what was the opening is this
one what it's the temple and then the
ball rolls and tries to crush him oh
that's the that's the opening of Raiders
yeah he steals the I think you're uh
you're deeply fantastic what's the
opening of Raiders um so I've always
wanted to it's one of those things like
what's on your bucket list like I want
to make an Indiana Jones game and I had
pitched Lucas I met some people there
and pitched them
back in 09
this Indiana Jones game concept
and
they wanted a public it's kind of the
deal fell apart they wanted to publish
it and we were a publisher and so we we
didn't do it and I didn't really have
the team to do it I just was going to
figure that out after we agreed to a
deal and well you know we made Skyrim so
it worked out
and then you know fast forward uh 10
years plus and uh you know Lucas now
part of Disney and they're doing a lot
more of Licensing and working with
people and so I knew some folks there
and said ah I have this idea that I
pitched a long time ago and they loved
it and again the internal team that I
had not only didn't have the time they
probably weren't as good a fit as
machine games who's done the Wolfenstein
series who is the perfect fit for this
game with storytelling and how they
record it and they are it's awesome
they're just doing an incredible job uh
with that game that's people are going
to be uh if you like Indiana Jones it is
it is a definite Love Letter to Indiana
Jones and everything with it can you say
if it's a little if it's more on the
action adventure like side
I like the actual experience of the game
I could go back I would just say it is a
mashup it is a unique it isn't one thing
intentionally so
um it does a lot of different things
that you know weave myself and and and
yurich and the folks in machine games
have wanted to
to do in a game so it's
it's a it's a unique thing
before I forget who do I
um
how many humans do I have to kill I mean
dragons to have to kill to get myself
somehow into uh Elder Scrolls six it's a
mod if anyone wants to create mods of me
and is that is that possible yeah it has
possible
uh while maintaining realism somehow
if you don't want you don't want a
person in a suit and tie
it doesn't make you put you in both put
you in Fallout you can wear that yeah
please put me so follows there's also a
culture of uh you do a mod where you
replace the mysterious stranger
there you go
that's a to-do task top mod right there
and you will have my deep gratitude and
more dear stranger for doing so
um what's the programming language for
mods is it mostly their use our internal
scripting language that's built into the
tool
okay I'm almost afraid to explore that
world because you will never never turn
back